hi guys today i'm gonna play amnesia for
the first time
ever i have heard of amnesia i've
watched
youtubers play it a long time ago when i
was
much much younger uh but this will
actually be the first time that i'm
playing amnesia myself
because amnesia rebreath is out and
why the hell not even though i am
actually quite
scared already because
i don't know the thought of pure
survival horror
it's just yeah it's just scary because
you have nothing to
um nothing to attack the monsters with
nothing to like protect yourself with
all you have to do
is be very good at hiding and very good
at running away
i think i'm quite good at running away
though i certainly think i'm the best at
hiding we shall see
this game shouldn't be played to win
immerse yourself in the world and the
story fear and darkness are your enemies
there you go guys if i don't win that's
good
because i'm playing it the way the game
told me to play it
so um i think that is a win in itself
really is that like a portrait down in
the bottom
right
i don't know what that is is it a mirror
oh you can't see because my head's in
the way it's just a little loading thing
there is a moment when you realize what
the pain has made of you
in hiding curled in on yourself
unable to show the world your face
acting on instinct lashing out
even at those closest to you
[Music]
time has passed and time is a thief
it has stolen your memories
the agony has faded but
so has every precious moment of joy
you have been hollowed out from the
inside
and there's nothing left of the person
you used to be
but you try you try to remember how to
smile
[Music]
you try to remember how to love
and one day you crawl out from your
hiding place and step
back into the world thanks for following
new account misery
you do what you must to survive
thanks for watching perspective going on
nothing don't worry pretending it's not
there won't make it go away
it's just turbulence it'll settle down
soon
yes yes i know it's hard though you know
your head tells you one thing but thank
you
demons nearby try to sleep i couldn't i
keep
imagining what might go wrong
that is one teddy bear
thanks for bothering i space jump jesus
christ where are they all coming from
thank you and there's so much more to
come
alex
it said my name
wait wait wait did they actually say my
name
okay so this is like the beginning of
bioshock
nah it's definitely a coincidence but it
was still cool
thanks for following victorvan
apparently i got raided
don't forget don't lose it no
no come on need to find him
he must understand don't forget
it's her it's all because of her
focus i am dizzy
i am still tessie
who's her do i still have my little uh
dippy creepy teddy i blame the teddy i
think the teddy is
haunted
look at me winning the game you can make
it
hint great hints need these hints
don't lose yourself
i see a shiny book up there
i i'm lord now i have rodden
it will help but you must try to keep
calm
or it will get worse do not allow
yourself anger
do not allow yourself to fear you
understand me tassie
[Music]
[Music]
there we go we made it back to our scene
but
where's like my husband husband
boyfriend i don't know
7
okay well i guess we're going to look at
this thing
oh it's my sketchbook i have to remember
she will die find salon
i've got like brain fog in china
i guess i might remember these along the
way
if i see certain things very ominous
very cool there's nothing in the
reminders but apart from this
okay my book my handwriting
i don't remember your drawings you're
such a good drawer
it might up the sensitivity
i like quite high sensitivity
what is this can i open it
cat tongues cat tongues
i can open it oh i can turn it around
i want to open up i'm gonna what's wrong
with me just find the entrance of this
bloody box
fine whatever you keep up with these
cats i don't want them
that's the doctor i'm here i'm here
is
oh the problem is i'm going to want to
do her accent because it's really fun
but then i'm gonna like offend people
because i'm really bad at accents
can anyone hear me
there were 12 passengers what happened
to the other 11
oh and two crew as well
great britain where we all talk like
this
according to the americans
okay
cool i guess that's it uh
oh okay
can i like use this
it's like an adventure game
well this is not what i would have
expected to see in amnesia
for god's sake help me
[Music]
i remember people were
hurt in the crash i was here
you were here i think
and then you went to the plane where's
sonia
i mean follow the footprints i guess but
let me just have a look around here
it's all right my friend we'll get you
out
eh i can't
open
foxy
right screw this i'm doing the
sensitivity
uh controls let's put you
right halfway
oh my god
leon jonathan give us a hand here
there you go finally what is this
nothing why did i oh whatever i'm going
wait can i read these in my case
left side bandages quickly
push these out of the way
something that's nathan
no rachel
who's rachel but we're good
[Applause]
where did we go
i'm going to fry out here
oh crap
what if i've just gone the entirely
wrong way which i really do think i've
gone
jasmine sobbing it's me
i probably should have gone the way that
the suitcases and stuff
there we go this is fine
wait thank you but we have no choice we
need to get them to shelter i know
it's sunny he's hurt you know what he's
like
let's get him down there then you and i
can sit on him while the dog takes a
look
don't worry the caves aren't far
[Applause]
capes caves
i just don't want to sound like how she
got back here and nobody else did
quite they're taking this weird stuff
uh yes antoine it is a scary game
why am i hearing like weird things in my
ears can you guys hear the game all
right can you hear the weird things in
your ears
this is just me please don't say it's
just me
oh yeah
are you there
this is a very wobbly whatever what am i
holding i
am going to leave it go away
littering
scuttling bugs maybe that's it but in my
ears
oh is that just part of her amnesia i
don't know
bye louise have a good time at work the
scuttling is back
look at that bloom ooh that lens flare
ooh
oh that poke all right
that god ray kind of
but it's good isn't it people have been
here
so we'll be shot with salt
instead of dying first i agree leon
what my point getting your hypes up
we're in this [ __ ]
[Applause]
thanks for following jacob apparently
this noise was
planning to show you going mad yeah
you're right i think maybe the noise is
to show that you're um
getting fried by the sun
oh there is a cave thank god
oh there is a note there is susan
dearest alfie the stories don't do this
place justice it is
amazing you've never seen anywhere as
busy as the market in algiers
the smells the flavors the colors and oh
the noise
i may have picked you both up a little
something you never know your luck
all my love always dad
that accent what was
that that was so funny
you never know i may picked you up a
little something
that's hilarious
[Music]
oh my essex boy in it oh tazzy
look at her hands such tiny perfect
fingers
hello hello my little one
is that salim
wait does she have a baby at home is
this good
okay it paused on the
loading for a while but don't worry
i think it i think it'd be working
hi from croatia long time follower first
time contactor
hey slicer sierra thank you for
reaching out in the chat and thank you
for following
i gotta press a button
i'll go on a table
it's all right i can manage come on
not far now
hello is anyone there salim
this is a very interesting way of uh
hunt him more tightly or the stitching
will tear why
i'm sorry i will be still here
i have you i have you
[Music]
sega we just restored a memory right
there
yeah this is i i like this way of
telling a story it's very different
she's already been through everything
but now she needs to remember
what happened to figure out what she can
do
or if she can save them where the bloody
hell they are can i chuck stuff
i want to chuck it i want it to smash i
want to smash it
want to be
destructive
with the medkit
this is us
i brought this here
what is it i i had
something to say to you whole speech
something poetic but
you don't need to say anything i know
it's just
i never thought this would happen any of
this you and me
i would never imagine there is no one
i would rather spend my time with really
really stop worrying i'm in love with
you you idiot
you idiot
this is cute second love story you're
wrapped up in a
horror game right which way do we have
we have a map
[Applause]
oh oh i can get matches wait these are
the matches
i don't want to waste them i'm not going
to use it i don't want to waste them do
i have to i don't want to waste them
i will use them when i have to not now
who are these people
i thought you should have this it
captures you both so well
is that them as well then but i can't
teach you
i won't stay here there's something in
the tunnels i swear
you won't be staying you'll be with us
and i'll take care of you come here
uh sorry you can't understand me all the
time arthur yeah i
i don't know i'll try i'll try to
my daughter by now you'll know about the
crash
and you'll know that our situation is a
bit sticky
we're off for a walk through the desert
to see if we can find a radio or
a village or some other sort of help
everyone's putting a brave face on it
but no one really knows what's going to
happen so maybe this is it
maybe this is the last you'll hear
if it is i'm sorry my love up
i suppose it's my fault for wanting a
big adventure
i should have stayed home after all
please
tell them both that i love them tell
susan that she's
the best girl in the world
and tell alfie to look after her sister
now i'm sitting here with tears and
behind me hands are trembling you know
i just don't know what right
i don't know how to say goodbye
i can't believe this is goodbye
i love you my darling girl i know in my
heart
we'll see each other again
even if it's not in this life you're
jonathan
that's sad
jasmine it's me it's not it's jasmine
chobani
her id
what a beautiful girl is that your
daughter
yes my father keeps nagging me for
grandchildren
did you leave her in paris yes
is she with her gran jasmine i'd like to
check the sadio samples are packed up
give me a hand of course mr mitchell
sorry hank ah
what a rude person interrupting their
discussion
i would never allow it
oh that's not creepy
at all
hello
oh that's how i chuck things wait give
me a plate
oh it didn't smash oh that's so
irritating i wanted it to smash
it's a cute car
whoa that car just disappeared
okay
oh paintbrush
why
did i miss something
more maps
portable radio transmitter
assume ten to nine people two days water
one day's food
rope is this like everything that they
had or everything
they wanted
maybe their inventory of some sorts
oh and this is everyone that was there
so who's yasmin yasmin is the hostess
salim is the guide we are
oh my god what's her name why have i
forgotten our name
what are we called we're not any of
these names
are we
we must be what are we calling i thought
we recorded like
starts with a t or something okay
i obviously have just forgotten our name
completely
jonathan you're jonathan he's the
engineer
when you tassie or something like yeah i
thought this up with the t
i don't know which one of these names we
would be because it's just eva
oh anastasia we must be anastasia
engineer and drafter
well
empty bottles don't need those
read that let's open this something here
oh this is us
tassie tassie really don't know how best
to handle this
sure she'll cope in the field but this
is not a difficult trip
we've been on much worse last year has
been hell for her that call from paris
she sent us a broke
i guess all i can do is look out for her
try to keep her busy
need to prod malik and raquel
rachel to do the same she's got salim
here too
which will help i really really hope
this is what she needs
that it can start many things were here
for the both of them
okay so we've had a bad pass something
happened i promise i won't bring this up
again but
i know this won't be easy on you first
time out again you know
so if you want a break you want to get
away from people
any of that just say whatever you need
okay thanks i guess
right
oh god oh no
thanks for following elsa miranda movie
amber
i'm sorry i'm butchering everyone's
names it's real bad
um yeah this isn't good
salim i'm sorry
oh that lucas i cannot bear it
the rest of you this is not sally's
fault
i am of sound mind she
killed herself because this lucas guy
died
oh i have to know how to do this
use a match [ __ ] with ah
ah see you can get it out on your hand
and you have a limited time to
to burn matches with it
brown matches brown candles
well i cannot read that can anyone in
the chat read this
maybe probably i don't know
there are definitely people out there
who are much more intelligent than me
can i brand things without this book
okay around the paper
i know him lucas
you guess i think yeah
[Applause]
oh oh i can put out the
flames too okay
okay well this is not the best so
i'm gonna go now
well that's two of them
to those who follow i am salim hanachi
i crashed with the crew of the cassandra
on march 3rd
1937. i and others were injured
we stayed while the rest of the crew
went for help
my companions are dead now no i'm not
the radio is broken i'm the second in
the house wait alone
there is some sort of creature here i
must go after the crew as best i can
they followed the path through the
mountain i will leave signs
tazzy if i do not find you
and by some chance you are reading this
know that you are my heart
my companions are dead now the radio is
broken
there's a creature here i must go after
the crew
so he was alive
he went after the crews he went back out
why couldn't you wait
i'll find you i promise he went back out
i think so why are we going back in
that's cool cup
i don't want the time to come
this
[Music]
can i pick it up now
no oh i thought i could pick it up in my
hands
uh i can't remember what i was just
saying oh yeah
i don't i don't want the monster to come
uh i feel like i shouldn't
maybe i should
but he has no more work until next week
i know that tazi has savings and i know
that something will come but
it is hard it is not just two of us now
i want to know that i'm keeping them
safe why is this like from his
diary i knew it
oh my gosh it's all so
dark the game is like particles
come this way but it's dark down there
game i don't want to
fine i'm not sure this is the best
anymore anymore any more for any more
anymore anymore any more match going out
animal animal oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
okay well
i have a little bit of light here at
least i just don't know where i'm going
i heard some weird noises that way so i
don't think i really want to continue
oh nice
there's bugs on the floor
[Music]
anyway
squash squash
squash all right
i don't want to waste all my bloody
matches
[Music]
or something yeah i feel you how do i
get a lantern
oh thank god what
[Music]
i think i'm just gonna have to use my
matches
i'm being really stingy with him
yes
yes
[Music]
anymore
nice i wish i had a lantern though
i have five matches
i heard something talking in my ear i
did not appreciate
that i'm a jumping i'm a champion
oh there's nothing up here
spooky
that's better living in the window
to the wall ah
i feel so much better in here oh is it a
safe room
let's lock it it reminds me of somewhere
else
nice it feels a bit like the shrine
back home
he's got pins in her elbows
matches matches
yay
matches matches
i'm just messing this place up sorry let
me put it back
matches
matches oh my god there actually are
matches in here
yes i love this get them out
get them out get the matches out get
them out
yes ow i just hit my headphones
i've been waiting for that that felt so
good
right
holy mother hear my plea
please save my friends and me
guys did you know that i'm a lyricist
singer somewhere in it mate
nope nope nope oh just went round and
cycle
let's try again
[Applause]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you everybody
what was that i don't know i wasn't
looking i was moving too fast
letter came from hank mitchell he offers
her work
a journey to french sudan i pray that
she will take it
it is what she needs what both of us
need
to be away from these memories and back
into the world
oh so this is why we're here something
happens with me
and then we came here to try and make me
feel better
and now everyone might be dead
apart from me maybe maybe they're not
but i have a feeling they are i could go
back
but i'm just going to go forward his
face is everywhere
this is the creature or is this the
entity the creature
where ships i think this might be the
creature this like black thing next to
it and this is the entity the creature
worships
let's test our balance and hope that
we're not
very heavy
i feel like i just wasted a match here
oh my god
is
oh my god what's my flashlight thing
again i forgot the button what's wrong
with me
i don't know ah
can we go please
these textures what are they they're so
scary
this little pixelated
[Music]
please bring me to the light
i don't want to waste any more magic
what
what the hell is wrong with me she is
turning into it
it's um trying to think of the name
it might not be like the same as um this
isn't where i
get there's people that live in the
caves
who end up eating each other becoming
cannibals and then they
because when you eat the flesh of
another human you come
back it's gone now completely as a
monster
camera with the name of it
keep wanting to say supercar bro but i
know it's not that
what is i thought that was a glitch
whoa
look light look at this stone
oh wait
wait can i pick it back up and then
will it slow again
[Music]
a wendy go yes guys that's what i was
talking about
wendigo
what the hell but i'm probably wrong
because we have some weird
funky ass rocks here
was this thing
on my wrist it feels alive
is it mine i i don't remember
[Music]
we have a converse
[Music]
how do we get through here
[Music]
wait which way that has come from
this is so cool
so
[Music]
it's making balls
[Music]
am i in like another dimension right now
so cool
hey how are you doing christ's name
how could i leave him i know i know it
makes sense everything he said but
i did such stupid [ __ ] sacrificing
[ __ ]
listen i know celine and i know
you i know what you're capable of he'll
make it
and you'll get back to him even if all
hell stands in your way i'm so
[ __ ] scared i know
oh what a cute picture
that reminds me i had a dream last night
that i had uh
my leg hairs were flowers
but some of them were dead so i had to
pluck them out
sleep well
it's quite disturbing
i wonder if they'll have to plug these
dead flowers out of the baby's head
i'll stop talking
torches someone's been here
anyone
i mean it's nice and bright here which
we like we like the light the light is
our friend
always happy to see the light
let me explore
i was able to meet them in the park this
afternoon after talking to the factory
manager dinar
a proud moment alice has learned to
count to three with her blocks
why is she leaving she did
she showed me these around it's like in
the park
he wants her to find them it's kind of
odd
to be honest
oh my god there's so many of these
things
i'm i'm just gonna go do it
oh
caves
they sound like you're under water
and they have the barnacles
that's so cool they're so cool
is there anything in here am i just
coming in to
look at the barnacles
is that it then
okay
oh [ __ ] oh
i fell i didn't think
that one through
at least the barnacles glow
it's not too dark
you know what this reminds me of uh
stranger things
the game isn't letting me look right for
some reason oh that's weird
okay now it is
i don't know why but my mouse input is
janky
that is weird i don't know why i can't
look around
i don't know if that's on purpose or
i love it i feel like this is a
mechanism
is it not
damn it i just wasted a wasted one
where in the name of god
and look at this place is that a person
you see that it can't be real but i'm
right and he looks like a person being
like
holding something
see that
that's cool
loving the sound design for this game
am i going the right way was i supposed
to go the other way
hmm
oh
he's so happy
that definitely is a person or a statue
or something like that
my bracelet it's glowing again
what are you doing
[Music]
whenever i look at the statue
it does look very pretty
[Music]
that's not good i wonder if this is one
of the people she was on the
thingy with i'm defeated
there's no way back there's nowhere to
go i've searched for a portal but there
is none
i have triangulated the weakest points
with levi's capital asians
but i cannot tear a rift for i do not
have a traveler's amulet
oh like i do obviously i did not heed
brendenberg's warning
yet what choice do they have to shallow
sense the orb
i had to whisk all and step through the
portal
there is no water and no other means of
sustenance i will not live long
if you read a traveler from whatever
world you come
if you comprehend and if you know enough
to speak to those of the human world
called
earth let them know this i
was the first to solve the mysteries of
the gate builders
i was the first human to breach the
boundaries between worlds i
professor thurston and lawyers herbert
of cambridge
england was the best of course cambridge
england god forgive me so this is
this is an alien world so i guess yeah
kind of his stranger things kind of vibe
because he's talking to what he thinks
could possibly be an alien
that's cool that's cool
well i am a human and i now know
[Music]
i won't be trapped not like this there
must be a way back
well he didn't have the amulet and i do
so
oh there's something in my face
all right
weak points
was he collecting the flowers i guess he
was doing research
so there are shadows of the dead in the
rooms those who lived here were human or
near it
so perhaps this was zazura after all
or eden oh you think it might be like
garden of eden before it went all
dark and i know
before adam and eve you know had the
apple
and were expelled from the garden of
eden maybe it was
withered i don't know uh anyway
but whatever this place was it shattered
there must have been the gate buildings
but what horror could cause such
destruction
surely even the shadow cannot destroy a
whole world
there's no sign of a portal even if i
were to find one the orb was lost in the
shadow
and i do not have another okay so he
came with some sort of
orb that he lost and now
a shadow these shadow people what we saw
before i'm guessing
i took it there's something else here
staring in the fog
i see bright lights as it hunts and here
it's
fries i do not think it's a light oh i
see bright lights as it hunts
so maybe that wasn't we didn't see the
monster earlier we just
saw one of these shadow people
that couldn't get back
no portal alternate alternative
[Music]
okay in here
i must explore for i must find a way to
return but step me into the fog is
accepting into a deep water
i'm lost in a sea of whisper and
confusion i need something to shut them
out
are they dead of this place are they the
dead at this place
or only by paranoia my strategy now is
to focus on myself clear my thoughts
step in and survey
as swiftly as i may number 10
it will be slow but it fears
well yeah
that didn't really i didn't really do
much good for you
but you tried
[Music]
are you supposed to do here
[Music]
uh i'm lost
did i not do
okay i don't think i want to just
go here
it's gonna be something else
[Music]
[Music]
that one read all this
[Music]
okay where's the weak points there i
don't even understand how to
work out these ramblings
anyone got any ideas
[Music]
oh hello
oh i thought i saw a way
looks like a jumper
okay i'm not doing that again
why is my my mouse honestly this is
actually annoying me
i wonder if other people have this issue
[Music]
okay
up please mouse
oh here we go right please left
a little bit oh this is infuriating
it only seems to be in these bits
here we go
slow down again
just follow the compass and hope for the
best i see lights
it's going crazy
[Music]
[Music]
whoa loving this place
see that event
here we go
this looks promising
come here you need to take your lid off
can i take your lid off please give me
consent to take your lid off
fine whatever obviously i'm not allowed
oh this is where i check
everything
oh my god oh my god
i'm staying crouched oh can you see can
you guys see
can you see shawnee
[Music]
i'm scared i don't know what i'm doing
do i go that way
do i go that way what other freaking way
is there to go
oh my mouse is [ __ ] up again
don't tell me that's part of the
gameplay no it can't be
oh mouse
the dead oh i don't need to worry then
do i
please give me near some [ __ ] lights
dude
oh i'm just wasting a match here
[Music]
christmas
here we go here we go here we go
oh it was just a light
come on
she doesn't know how to crouch walk
upstairs what happened to them
hello
looks like they would turn to stone or
uh mud
okay sure sure i'll run
wait what how am i alive i could have
swore i just died right then
where the [ __ ] am i
help help help this is where i just came
i'm not good at navigation
especially in the dark
even with this bloody compass it's
getting lost all the time
here we go all right i must have just
fell to the
floor below right come on steps come on
it's not that hard
which way do you want to go compass
tells you this way but
there's a prank here
but i want to go on going over the back
maybe i was supposed to go this way
hello
oh my god i have no [ __ ] idea where
i'm going
my compass i just got a safe point for
some reason
here we go
through this i'm running
[Music]
i just run past the spooky things until
i realize it's nice and spooky then i
come back and investigate
i don't know what could have done this
okay let's go
[Music]
oh it's not from the airplane
oh where am i oh
i think we're in our house or something
yeah look it's my drawings on the walls
it's so beautiful
look at that buttocks
um
uh artist is so cool
i like looking at people who can do art
that's so cool
food is ready can i see
it's not finished it's terrible
absolutely get out of here
oh look it's creepy doll thing but i'm
gonna look at this first
i know i have to remember
ministry of the interior notice of
rejection
oh so she was doing it for a job i guess
and they rejected her sad
[Applause]
i would just put that right in the bin i
don't want any reminders
actually stephen king said that he
used to put all of his rejection letters
uh on a nail and he got so many that he
had to fill
a a bigger nail he had to get a bigger
nail to fill it
before he managed to get a hit which i i
think is
really really interesting i like reading
up
or hearing stories of people who are
well
known and stuff like how many how much
they failed because a lot of them failed
a lot before they succeeded it makes you
feel kind of like
okay you just gotta get used to failing
really
oh this doll i just
find it creepy because i used to have a
little monkey when i was a kid
and it had a uh it used to talk and it
had like battery operation in it
um but it was only supposed to talk when
you pressed its lips together but it
used to just
talk in the middle of the night and wake
me up when nothing was touching it
alice wonderland hell yeah
hey alyssia thank you so much really
appreciate it
i did not realize i'm just trashing my
kids bedroom i think aren't i
sorry kid your mom's a very messy person
i was 16 i think and i must have driven
him crazy
but no curfew no locked doors
just this compass he said it was so i
would always find my way
home i wish i'd known him better
so do i oh who's that like her dad or
something
it's gotta be
okay that's a nice little memory
that you have though is sally gonna end
up being someone creepy
you're creeping me out you're creeping
out the chat
or just me
i don't care about the paperwork this is
as official as i need it to be
i love you salim put the data ring on
oh my heart i will put the damn ring out
and you will wear mine
but they're cute though oh
i don't want him to be creepy but he is
look it's humming
sell him
i'm coming back in the same room
without the drawings
[Music]
i'm here
no baby
[Music]
no not remember her elise
no no no no no no
is
i was not expecting that what
that's gonna be cute though that sounds
kind of cute though
that was cool i like that little blast
in the past
alice sell him
no it felt sorry
something's different
i feel like i don't fit my body
what the hell i'm heavy oh my god
feels like oh
god what's wrong
did i eat something i mean we've all
been there don't don't
don't feel uh embarrassed yeah
we've we've all been through something
like that
oh wait is it gonna be is she gonna be
like pregnant or something weird
has she been impregnated by some weird
alien
i mean it makes sense what you're just
looking at a fetus
oh yes
oh god freaking i might have to go
soon because this mouse issue is
annoying me i'll try and fix it for next
stream
that's what the doctor said
oh come on it's a bundle of bloody wood
just
burn i can take it with me
that's not like game that's not right
game
i know what i'm supposed to do don't
give me your hints i'm trying to burn
some
wood which should be doable
find whatever game
professor herbert rifts
holes between worlds
excuse me
oh i see
well i guess i'm going to see this
little hole
i wish i had a lantern
oh my god no
oh oh oh matches
i hate hate this
go go go go go girl go girl
go girl go girl oh my god
[Music]
don't worry i can see some light is
coming
soon here's a ladder
this is uh taking a while
i'm not sure i can't cope with this
here's the shadow people
look see there
it must be what the doctor gave me
yes
no
don't like that i don't like the blatant
jump scare stop it
i don't expect it it just comes out of
nowhere
ah
anything in here
and if i just look at the chat and
someone's like are you not afraid
and then i know i've just screamed so
loud
so i think that answers your question
oh my god i've already got to start
looking around for matches but the same
time i just want to run through the dark
beds
he was here the monkey you had him on
the airplane didn't you
we said we would put him away what's
wrong
poor monkey we should
clean him stitch him up here
he's so tightened oh my what
okay
i was just thinking um i'm trying to
like
figure out what went wrong with her
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i remember
i'm pregnant
she hasn't had the baby yet in paris
okay expedition we nearly didn't come
because i was
ah i'm going to have another child oh
another child
and she does have christ
where did you go
gotta look after me and my baby bump
well this is quite a unique idea for a
protagonist
to play as uh in a horror game
definitely a pregnant
letter
definitely ups the vulnerability of it
i can't all anything cannot see
anything here we go
a bloody hampering no no no no no please
send him
no please my love i'm here now please
stand
stay for me please my hand
heal my heart
what do i do what do i do now
who's supposed to find you
huh
my heart
oh he left me with a torch
i know i will not live
it does not hurt now i have lost you
tanzi it is only for time
i know you will escape you carry
something so
precious live for us does he
live for the child live
and be free and one bright day we will
all
be together again know that you
are my heart you are my heart
cute
thank you salin sorry you did
okay
i'm aware that this lamp will not last
forever
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] this i can't do this
not without you not without you why did
you have to go
it's not just about you anymore you got
a kid at home
and you got a kid in your body for the
giant
yes come on
there's got to be something you can do
oh come on work damn you
i just tried to turn on my um flashlight
torch thing
i guess it's not working what hello
is someone there wow that is
wow that's the orb isn't that the orb
that the guy used to
get in oh it's empty
[Music]
i think that's her word for him
that's cute
i like these little drawings
i just got an achievement widow woohoo
i got the widow achievement
god in heaven look where we are
what am i going to do
just look at me oh
cool i can check in on my baby
i can't believe i forgot this
but this isn't right is it i wasn't this
far gone
unless something's it wasn't even three
months this feels more than four
you've been here for a lot longer than
you thought
nothing i can do about it
i suppose this if nothing else
this is my reason to get out of here
yeah
yeah i know a sister for alice
or my brother maybe
but only if i can get her
why now there's nothing i can do about
it
i just need to be careful
i'll get through this
both of us
wait
wait can i am i supposed to be able to
get up here
this mouse thing is annoying to have on
me
come on you can do it run and jump
jump out there come on you can do it
do it just grab it grab it
fine let's go down this way
hey i took the parkour path
come on
hello any matches in here
oh
this one might be something in there
see it really looks like i should be
able to get up there
there that really oh god we were so
close
[Music]
wow she's fast
can i like open it or something
hmm
ah before dropping down on that
[ __ ]
got to be more careful now we've got a
messenger
um i've got a check everywhere for these
matches
oh my god i am not actually have to end
the stream this is actually i don't know
if you guys can see
but the amount of times i'm trying to
move my mouse and it's just not like
even now
i can't move it left it's very annoying
it's just
i'm gonna overshoot
i'm guessing this will be locked
it's got a friendliest places count your
lucky stars archer it could have come
down in the middle of nowhere
don't worry jonathan supplies water
so they did make it that something they
have been there there's no one home
michaels would have gathered the plies
they have been helpful
it's a lot now
[Applause]
hide mode makes you less visible unable
to move what is hide mode
oh it's when i hold control oh that's
cool
does mouse have any decimal sensor no
and it never does this with anything
else
but i'll i'll look into it
honor oh i can do this honor
and enforced fidelity
the legion is our papa it's max's
formula
okay okay
sergeant fournier is a fornicator
is weird
hell yeah looking away those matches you
know how important they are
okay so this is
people's families that live here in the
desert
i gave
what's this random numbers
since i am
okay i don't want to go in here just yet
though oh there's so many different ways
to go i don't know
okay let me i'm not gonna go up i'm just
gonna have a little look
ooh help me oh yeah
there you go now the door can open
yes i'll move these sandbags
anyway before we progress
this way
hello
tea
anything in the cup nothing in the top
anything in this cup
and there hackim recounted the tale of
the local tribe the kel
hannon they were tauric that refused
the call to islam for their own ancestor
tin hannon a bringer of healing and
fertility
walked the sand and how should they
disbelieve the evidence of their own
eyes
there was fighting as there always is in
such matters
but the kell hannon were wealthy and
made their peace
through his trade and salt and meat
okay
anything
matches
matches matches
yeah what have i reached maximum
match capacity death
okay well there was also a little cave
that i saw back here so i'm gonna check
that out too
maybe it was my mouse sensor oh hello
molly do you know her is that you
i'm from sudan mr sterling this is
algeria
it might be tenhan the mother of the
tuarek
it's a strange style though
should let the goddess of fertility so
this is gonna be something weird like
i'm
the only one who survived because i'm
pregnant
and they need me or
or they maybe they kind of oddly now
they don't worship
me because you can still die in this
game
but you know it's gotta be something
like that something to do with
fertility
what is this what is this used for
i'll put that back
nah
okay now we shall progress
whoa scorpion bye montage thanks for
coming
not far yeah we're good we got this
is it the orb again
oh
[Music]
[ __ ] i wish
i love the way she swears
i think jonathan starts here another
triple crown higher met in london
has worked on a ton of projects but
never outside england
nice guy but like an excited puppy
desperate to have a proper taste of
africa
he'll work well with tassie and eva but
we need to make sure leon doesn't
steamroll
him steamrolling what does that even
mean to steamroll somebody
ah jonathan's great first time out in
the world and
everything's a wonder it's like having a
kid alone
oh jeez sorry tazzy
oh cause she's pregnant
welcome to the end of the world oh malik
leon
let's take a look ahead the rest of you
hold tight here
won't be long tardy what's the sign say
my french is piss-poor just
um just that they were a long way from
home
the accent what's the sign say
my mother is pissed paul
yes yes that's how that's how we all
sound yes
either that or the essex look at her
jump whoa
pakora parkour mama
can i get let's put the paco off all
these rocks
it's down here
i'm too good at this i'm too good at
finding this
precious tune and look at you
that's cute this is the baby with the
leaves growing out of his head
now leaves just follow it wherever it
goes
hey socap and the doctor vlogs
oh i always forget to press the button
we were here i i remember being scared
why
crikey look at the size of this place
that was my thoughts exactly to be
honest
crikey look at the size of this place
there you go
i kind of just want to go in but i also
know i should probably explore
there's so much to see
where do i even begin
can i open this box
most this game i just end up looking
down at boxes
i can't do anything with that
i got oil yes
i didn't even know i was looking for
that but i'm glad i found it
oh
malik ah
trouble from he's in i uh algiers
already not much to say here malek's
handling
forward prep as usual buy-in supply
lists and such remind
right i don't know if this is like
raquel or rachel
i think it's like ratchet rachael i
don't know
to wire any extra needs to him in
algiers
make sure to introduce him to rachael
earlier he can be good back up
stop him doing something stupid same as
he's done for me a million times
also talk through the tassie situation
with him he'll
do anything for her even if she doesn't
know it
that's cute
you remember marrakesh where mama got
into that argument with your dad about
the mules
he was so furious but all he did was
stand there and say
it's your decision mr victor never even
raised his
voice well i think he's getting close to
that with the freeze
positively sarcastic
let's take a look in that building on
the left there valley you and me up
front
there's so many buildings so i don't
know which one to go in
i just want to get oil oil
over here i think this is a water pump
water pump
in here
i'll just leave a trailer mess
everywhere i go
oh no i'm stuck help
help i'm a stick
okay there we go
heavy barrel
i i'm just not thirsty
i should be i know but i don't think i
can stomach it
if you insist
the water come out
i am not passing up a chance to get more
oil so i am being very
thorough
some doors i can go into
that's the doctor
where's that radio coming from in here
right there i'll be right back i need to
explore first
everywhere
for oil
oil
oil yes
i will not be satisfied until i get
maximum oil and maximum match i've got
maximum match i just need maximum oil
i got maximum match
there are so many doors they're really
just gonna let us enter all these doors
quartermaster stores
no entry without authority
of captain left here
quartermasters only oh interesting
what the hell is this are people still
around here
does anything his pick up okay
i'm going back
i'm just gonna have a little look up
here
wait it's a radio here it's very close
whoa i needed that chair i didn't even
mean to i just
kicked it all the way over here
yep
wow
i don't even know my own strength
alicia who's behind you there's no one
behind me
see nobody
this is quite cool
ah so open i'm not used to like i swear
the first amnesia wasn't this
open was it i feel like there's so much
options right now
okay it's gotta be in here surely i
don't know where
we're gonna go in here anyway
can i hello sir
cool
this wasn't what i wanted what am i
doing why am i in here
[Music]
there's a little girl behind you in your
room don't say that that's
that's real creepy but i can luckily i
can see myself in the in the camera
all right
ah okay so i gotta blow up the door but
i will do that
at a later date let's get back out why
is this
well i bet you they're all gonna be
locked now
oh this one's not though
mama's here so don't you
crash
i'm here i'll always be here
still loading yeah
so i gotta blow up that door but i want
to
check out all this anyway i think this
might be where the radio was
i don't know where the radio was but it
sounded like it was over in this
direction so maybe it was inside this
building
man
pretty sure i saw that uh
that scene from like a trailer
gameplay trailer or something
i don't want matches i
got to get to that radio
yes i wonder how many you can have
what the max is maybe five i'm guessing
like five
ah one sec i'm looking for oil i'll get
to you
keep talking please don't stop okay
i need to get in there no come
on
come out here
oh my gosh the barrel is too big
can you please move
it's getting stuck on the spikes
maybe i'll just here we go
oh my god oh my god
what did you just say about jasmine
well i don't even know if i'm going the
right way oh my god boys
what is this place why am i here what am
i doing
the [ __ ] why am i hearing footsteps
all right so that's how i peak okay
what's this
multiple deaths
request reinforcements stopped
stop captain left of the
end request reinforcement urgent stop
captain
[Applause]
captain is is not a good guy he's
basically killing everybody
i don't know it's not going to help
anybody
shipment delay
i'm a genie in a bottle
okay
i feel like i'm moving away from it
instead of towards it
mama please talk to peppa for me please
he's not replied to my letters
there's no place for me the men are
crawl and the land is cruel i beg of you
i beg of him i will do everything
anything
to make amends if he will not take pity
ask if he truly wants the family name to
die out here in the dust
what what what is happening here
the game has lost me
there's something here
spring arm bed frame it's like a big
ass weapon
why do i keep singing that bloody song
anyway
oh
nope over there are matches
oh my god i thought someone locked me in
here then wait
dude
oh my gosh it was nothing it's just me
being silly don't worry about it
come on i want to open up get off get
off plate
i can hear babies and whispering
oh my god let's do this
maybe i should try and find something
else quickly
anything no i turned it
i was like panicked so i pressed it
twice and then i put it out
damn it
the wind don't you dare do that again
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it i'm not going back and
whoa
hello
no no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
i'm
why are they putting jump scares in my
face i don't appreciate it
it's a very cheap way of getting a scare
i want to go back to read [ __ ]
i knew i would make it
oh sorry my head's bashing against it
the inner desert the ifrit
is a genie of fire and flame a vengeance
called upon a murder of implacable
unstoppable the death of cities it rises
from desolation from broken man to
science
[Applause]
nope
the voice alone in the desert the cry of
one bereft and in need of aid yet the
voice is borderless and unflashed spread
of air and dreams it assails the weary
and the
delusion lowering them from their path
into the wilderness
they may search in vain while sometimes
nice nice
nice nice nice
[ __ ] nice one
the asha mother is a genie of
in the wilderness healing of wild and
capricious she cannot be summoned
but if her sympathy is aroused she may
choose to pursue her favor
giving of her body to quench the thirst
of the dying and guiding those who
wonder
[Music]
i'm not gonna lie i'm not really taking
it all in because i'm just
dad no can those creatures be anywhere
anytime
i don't like it i haven't found any
matches here
i guess i'm not gonna go back then i
guess i'm just gonna go forwards
wait is this back or forwards i think
this is
back why why i'm buying a [ __ ] light
i guess because i buy a dead body too
maybe
but you got some more matches
michael's like was that a bad scare for
you
yes michael that was the best scare for
me okay
i prefer those and there's little jump
scares that come out of your face
of course you can scream at that but
it's not as freaky as being like oh i
didn't get to check out this letter i'm
going to go backwards and then suddenly
seeing something
scuttle yeah that was
uh very
very scary maybe up here
screw you i lit this lamp i don't need
you
somehow yeah
how
how am i gonna get there
i feel like i should be using my brain
but at the same time i'm just scared
too scared to use brain
it's very dark in here
i'm gonna go in here
light some stuff
oi light
okay
this is where i was read this
no dustin desert arid plain i dream of
you i call your name
a flower a flower blooms the petals fall
sand glass empties still i call 10 years
gone my time is done
i journey home my battles won there's no
one waiting
no one there just echoes an empty chair
ooh good little poem about the war right
there
i don't know which war but to war in
general i guess
where is this scary monster gone
could i get into the radio room from
above somehow
for the hint i'm just gonna get
this working so we found like that
we did see this somewhere didn't we yeah
oh and then that pulley
oh right oh bloody out i already have it
don't i
did i use this somewhere no
ah there we go
hmm maybe not maybe that's not
everything
[Applause]
because it's broken isn't it
i would need to fix the bottom of it i
guess
i don't know how
oh i got lamp oil small
we've got lamp oil medium oh it can have
four
and three
so how do i fill this thing
the key i found it in the tank with
arsenal written on the label
i do not remember finding a key i'm not
gonna lie
parkour skills are filming out
stop i hate when you do this
yeah everybody i really don't think i
can get up
just keep thinking i can make that jump
but i really don't think i can make that
jump
bye abe196 thanks for coming
ah
nah this isn't gonna help me now is it
you've got this
i don't know what the hell i'm doing
what do you mean i got this i don't know
what i'm doing
back in this room
[Music]
hmm
so
nearly there just gotta figure out
what's going here
i'm just gonna fix the bottom
[Applause]
hmm
the question
can i get you
can you help me
i need to put boards back
oh my god it's working how the hell i
did not expect that to work but
cool
oh
it's talking it's
a little creature put his little arm out
to the wall
it's okay i'm just gonna keep going that
way
i think hello
hello
hello can i get two radio room please
two step this floor doesn't look too
sturdy
i mean i am carrying a baby
[Music]
i hate this oh my god i need to get took
a place where i can stop playing because
i'm getting too freaked out
that's a very light room i like this
room but what was it
what did you see miss triana
i i i don't know it was
just a shadow yes
it was a ghoul
did it stick its hand through the wall
with you
as well yasmine because it did to me
this is really interesting that it's
always light outside technically
um yeah
it's weird because you go inside and
it's so dark and
usually in horror games anyway it's
always nighttime
so this is just very different which i
appreciate
oh the good captain
he has to play the fair-minded statesman
pretend that kale
the kell hannon are more than savages
give them the benefit of the doubt
he's an ass that lot up at presents
are worse than the bedouin even the
tour egg do not trust him i remember the
stories maxine told they skinned two
of albert's troop left them there to die
screaming
salt rubbed into the flesh all in the
name of this great mother of theirs
they put on pretty smiles and give the
captain painted rocks
but oh painted rocks like the magic
special rocks
but they're the worst of devils they
aren't so many
slaughter them and make excuses later if
i were a commander
maybe we'll do this again okay
so we're talking about the people that
live here the like
skin others and
are basically savages oh yeah
okay well this room was a nice nice
little break
monster
hillary
20 seconds oh wait am i going crazy
i don't think so i shouldn't be i'm in
the light i'm in a lightroom
22nd of march 1929 instant insistent
legion doughy killed men reports and
world tag
they are jumping at shadows every noise
is hailed as
lion or jackal saint fornia suspects kel
hannon are responsible
fort placed on alert
oh this is a lengthy one 13th of march
deputation from the kell hannon further
complaints of behavior of
legios loretz and desprosias around the
woman
i don't understand these words
acknowledge complaint assurance it will
not be repeated
ordered punishment but not in front of
the locals
apparent that the men need some activity
to keep them occupied
i've given orders to start excavation of
the lower chambers
18th of march men have broken through to
an
underground chamber impressive
architecture
rubble to be cleared and then
evaluations of sight
lavoie reports activity on lower slopes
speculates retaliation from village but
hard to believe
god doubled 19th of march de la croix
and des brosiers absence saint fornia
belizeans behind the system
21st of march uh khalid found dysrosius
and zelda dead
no sign of de la croix
suspect argument accidental killing and
dissertation
so are these people
maybe hurting us and like falling around
freaking me out are they delacroix
and the people who were here before did
them wrong
so close aren't we
that's good stuff that's the good stuff
that's also good oil is better
i'm not already using it
i don't know why i just got my
flashlight out at him
take this look at this it's a flashlight
[ __ ]
she's already figured out how to manage
sterling fairchild
even to freeze as a real way with
smiling and pretending she gives a damn
i like her oh thank you i'm glad you
noticed these
wonderful traits about me no i'm not
i'm not gonna say it's me anymore
okay okay dead person cool cool
oh we can go in there
what i mean why not it's just a few dead
people though
okay um we're not
we going to die
look at this chap here suicide
why why would they do that
why do bloody things
yep let's leave i don't want to be in
here anymore
whoa whoa
i didn't see it i don't want to see it
i'm not here for it
i'm just moving i'm keeping on moving
oh
oh no i think i went the wrong way oh
guys
uh-oh i'm back out here now
it's okay
here we go right
let's resume oh this is where
that's where i just was surely this is
where i gotta go right
no
i don't think so actually
no this is not right
hello it's my shadow
let's get back around again
yep i saw it
do you want to go down here
is that the radio room i can't hear him
[Music]
anymore
is it down there
have we only been down there
i think we have
oh yeah
dead people honor
everywhere
that's well that's this is the room
i mean if the floor
you know what it's basically the end of
the stream so i'm just going to try this
now
if the floor is actually that bad can i
take off these
boards then uh what if i just
don't be careful i suppose if this goes
away
downstairs exactly that's what i'm
thinking
i was hoping that it would give way
darn it that's a shame
why am i going crazy and by like
screw it maybe i will go down
okay
have we been here
oh i have been here oh this is annoying
gosh
oh dear how am i gonna
find a better way
i've been here look
what what why is this
here why do they have the eiffel tower
there i'm so confused
is this an illusion
has she lived here before did she paint
this
that was weird
the kell hannon talk of their guardian
spirits or perhaps the weirdest goddess
a woman all in grey who haunts the
desert and protects their people against
the specter of death they call her te
hanu
and leave her gifts of desert
[Applause]
okay well
i haven't
at least that was a different game i
guess
but alas we must
venture upstairs again
it's old french colony oh maybe maybe
where should we go guys
[Music]
oh god i'm gonna die
that was not nice a doll can you please
open doors for me i do have a key though
actually now that i remember
arsenal
yeah let's just try a key with all these
doors
this looks heavy enough if i can just
get it uh
game what
what
i think i do need to shove off
out
ah
come back come back i need you
it's a tiny wheel it's not going
anywhere
tiny wheel a tiny wheel i have a tiny
wheel for it
okay come on guys spanner
we need to find another wheel
somewhere oh
why can't it just be right next to it
dead people dead people
pressure plate didn't do anything
why is there a bowel here
maybe the wheels here
oh don't tell me the wheel is downstairs
oh my god my shadow scared me
where is the other wheel
no it can't be downstairs because then
i'd have to
hold it and carry it all the way oh
[Music]
in the dead pressing room
maybe i could take it off here can i
take a wheel off one of you guys
please please
it's for a good cause i swear
hi fellas anna we've been here
a few times i just i'm looking for a
wheel
uh maybe uh i can take one of these i'm
sorry
i'm so oh here we go i got it i'm going
now
i'm i'm sorry please let me through
thank you
got the wheel
that did it that did the trick
i guess that worked yes it did oh crap
uh
[Music]
[Music]
wait no hello
hello doctor are you there yes yes i'm
here
is that you oh thank god it's tazzy
does it
not really not at all i can't remember
anything
i'm pregnant i'm lost
send him a thought i'm in a fort
we were here before i think i don't know
doctor where are you we have found help
people village but yes mean
it's not well the frog
yes the fort go through the mountain
parts and it is maybe an hour beyond
there
the mountain bus yes yes i see the
village
here on the map oh thank god
doctor please there's something else i
uh
i keep blacking out it feels like i'm
losing control i am aware
of your recent problems
i did something
doctor
i did something i did something
what did i do
pen
yes please oil can be used to refill
your latin
i know game but thanks for letting me
know anyway
really appreciate how you're always
looking out for me
okay so we need to go
the doctor said it was through the past
here on the map
so i just need to find my way to that
guess so i need to get out of here first
can i get out
look at this there's bound to be
something useful
oh can't we just get out of here this
place gives me the creeks
they're dead and gone i can't hurt you
now
[Applause]
ah jesus
the door gets to the door
lock the damn door
[Music]
yep
good
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
okay we're out we have survived
keep makka here he is
look
oh maka maka
[ __ ] i think
i think it stopped i don't think it
likes the light
i don't know maybe maybe it doesn't i
don't know maybe it doesn't like the air
i
don't know like your leg
i can make it
[Applause]
oh
after it killed jonathan we escaped
through the big gates into the past
all right that's it guys that's all
you're getting for tonight
but i think that was um enough scares
you got some good jump scares you got
some um
some actual scares not just the
flashing in your face and uh hopefully i
didn't
blow out your eardrums that's all you
can hope for
in these streams really isn't it
um but yeah thanks so much for watching
i'll definitely be playing this again
next week
next thursday uh i want to take this
time to just remind you
that on halloween at 8 pm bst um
there will be a halloween uh
spooky story straight from my nightmare
for you i've done it in unreal so i've
like done a little cinematic in a game
engine
and i'm going to tell you a story about
one of my nightmares
and jamie has done music for it and it
sounds amazing and yeah i just can't
wait to share
share it with you so you have something
to look forward to on halloween
anyway thanks again for spending the
evening with me i'll see you
again next week next thursday same time
9pm
as mostly always if we don't have
technical difficulties
but this is this was good so far i don't
think this
isn't as scary as i thought it was going
to be
but i feel like it's a long ramp up
which i'm totally fine with because the
the narrative's intriguing
i want to read the notes i want to find
out about
the lore of the world that i'm putting
there's obviously been a lot of thought
put into it so i want to
learn and understand it and if it was
just go go run run run i wouldn't have a
chance to do that
kind of like outlast did that a little
bit where you wanted to
kind of have a breather and take in the
narrative and
the scenery even and by the end of
outlast especially outlast two
you were just running like on the go all
the time so
i appreciate this is a little bit slower
but i am
expecting it to ramp up the scares
and to have because i just remember
amnesia being a lot of the times where
you'd be in a scenario where you felt
kind of semi-safe
and then all of a sudden a monster would
come in and then you would have
to hide you couldn't just simply
run out of the exit so i'm definitely
expecting those
kinds of scenarios to come soon